hey guys let's talk about money
you know there's a lot of guys who pray
to God and ask him to help them
financially but they are not obeying his
word what he says they need to do when
it comes to money
if that's you it means that you never
learn how to deal with money in a
Biblical correct way so even if God does
bless you with money it's like throwing
water into a bucket full of holes
it will not help you money doesn't fix
the root of the problem for a lot of men
it might actually make their problems
bigger
because they haven't learned how to work
with their money the right way
and the right way is always God's way
do you know who's the smartest person
ever I mean the wisest
I mean you can't tell him anything
at all when it comes to money
in all history he's the richest
more than Elon Musk more than Solomon in
all these Glory do you know who it is
it's God so if God tells you something
about money then you need to listen to
him because he knows what he's talking
about
and the Bible has a great deal to say
about money and if you're just man if
you just if you're open and listen
it will change your life forever I'm
going to give you 10 biblical financial
principles every man must know and
practice
let's start with number one
never create debt try your best to live
a debt-free life you know as I grew up
my my mom I can just hear her voice now
she always said Donnie
Scott Morgan
Afrikaans my language Daniel never make
dead so how do you do that how do you
live a debt-free life
well you never make debt in the first
place and if you have debt you need to
pay it off as fast as you can
Proverbs 22 verse 7 the rich rules over
the poor and the borrower is the slave
of the lender
and Romans 13 verse 7 says pay to all
what is owed to them
taxes to whom taxes are owed Revenue to
whom revenue is owed
respect to whom respect is owed
[Music]
honor to whom honor is owed
and here it comes verse 8 listen closely
oh no one anything except to love each
other
for the one who loves another has
fulfilled the law
owe no one anything
who do you owe something right now
think about it write it down
or what you owe the bank right now
don't take that expensive holiday don't
buy that new car or that brand of shoes
that you want that you don't need
pay off your debt first Proverbs 22
verse 26 says be not one of those who
give pledges who put up security for
debts if you have nothing with which to
pay why should your bed be taken from
under you
if you want to buy something that costs
a lot of money don't just jump in
recklessly making debt to buy this thing
because you'll spend years to pay off
the interest rate and it'll be high and
so let's say it's a house right and
you'll spend years just paying off the
interest rate itself you're not even
paying for the house so they're
basically stealing your money
so instead of
taking this time years to pay off the
interest rate just take that exact same
amount of years save up the money and
then use it for the house
never spend money you don't have on
things that you don't need
I mean some of you probably heard this
before it is so simple and yet a lot of
men don't do this
and for some reason a lot of men spend
this money on the things they don't need
on people that they trying to impress
which is so silly for me
you know Galatians 6 7 says for whatever
one sows
that will he also reap
there's always always consequences to
the decisions that you make your actions
so if you spend money that you don't
have what do you think is going to
happen
that's foolish
Jesus said in Luke 12 15 take care
and be on your guard against all
covetousness
for one's life does not consist in the
abundance of his possessions
greed man the sinful flesh greed is a
terrible thing do not be greedy for
things that you do not have
is dangerous and life is a lot more than
just the material things around you you
don't need the latest phone or the
newest and best clothes all the time you
don't need to fit in with what is
trending and buy the latest or newest
thing
you know I see this in a lot of
prosperity churches where people just go
there they worship God not because they
love him they want to obey him they want
to live life righteously in Holiness
Growing With God studying his word no
they're going there because they want
prosperity in this short temporary world
so they can just spend all the things
the money on their fleshly desires
living luxury
a selfish
and you know the Bible actually says in
Hebrews 13 Verse 5 keep your life free
from Love of Money
and be content with what you have
for he has said I will never leave you
nor forsake you
and one Timothy 6 says but godliness
with contentment is great gain for we
brought nothing into the world and we
cannot take anything out of the world
but if we have food and clothing
with these we will be content
ask yourself right now are you content
with only food and clothing with what
God has already given you
or do you pray to him and complain
because you want want want
verse 9 says but those who desire to be
rich fall into temptation into a snare
into many senseless and harmful desires
that plunge people into ruin and
destruction
verse 10 For the Love of Money is a root
of all kinds of evils it is through this
craving that some have wandered away
from the faith and Pierce themselves
with many pangs
being content with what we have
it it protects us you know from falling
in that trap of constantly wanting more
material stuff
because you know you can't get happiness
from that
you can have peace and joy in the little
things of life that God gives you
and you receive your joy fullness
purpose everything you need you receive
in Jesus Christ you get it from him
all these other things that's just a
bonus
nah the money you do have you get that
from God anyway
you can take away your job it can give
you another one he can bless you
and you need to be responsible with
whatever he chooses to give you
it's a responsibility
if you don't use it wisely it might take
what he has given you and give it to
someone else
Jesus said in Matthew 25 then you ought
to have invested my money with the
bankers and at my coming I should have
received what was my own with interest
now listen to what he says verse 28 so
take the talent from him and give it to
him who has the ten talents
for to everyone who has will more be
given and he will have an abundance but
from the one who has not even what he
has will be taken away
now we know that this verse is talking
about a lot more than just money but we
can also apply this verse to money
because everything that we have
including money comes from God in the
first place right and so we have a
responsibility to use it wisely so you
also have a responsibility to use your
money wisely and not spend it just
carelessly on things that you do not
need
now let's move on to the next one
invest
Proverbs 21 verse 5 says the plans of
the diligent lead to profit as surely as
a haste leads to Poverty investing your
money can be a way to increase what you
already have right your wealth
but also it can financially secure your
future which is very important but you
need to invest wisely and not take
unnecessary risks Grant Cardone said
investing puts money to work the only
reason to have money is to invest
you know there's a lot of guys who say
well yeah I don't know how to do that so
I'm just going to leave it has it ever
occurred to you that you can educate
yourself I mean YouTube is free you can
read books Google
or speak to a financial advisor
and you can even ask AI in the world
that we live in today it's well it's
interesting and it's a little bit not
sure where the future is leading us but
why not use the resources that you have
so I did a test today I asked Chad GPT
the following question what are the best
ways to invest money
[Music]
Chad deputy said there are many ways to
invest money and the best approach will
depend on your individual financial
goals risk tolerance and time Horizon
here are some common investment options
one stocks
investing in stocks involves buying
shares of publicly traded companies
stocks can provide the potential for
high returns over the long term but they
also come with higher risk than other
Investments
bonds
investing in bonds involves buying debt
securities issued by governments or
corporations bonds provide lower returns
than stocks but they are generally
considered less risky
three mutual funds
a mutual fund is a professionally
managed Investment Portfolio that pulls
money from multiple investors to buy a
diversified mix of stocks bonds and
other assets
four exchange traded funds ETFs
ETFs are similar to mutual funds but
they trade like stocks on an exchange
ETFs provide a convenient way to invest
in a diversified portfolio of assets
five real estate
investing in real estate can provide
long-term growth and income potential
but it requires more upfront capital and
can be more complex than other
Investments
alternative Investments
this category includes Investments like
Commodities
cryptocurrencies and hedge funds
alternative Investments can provide
diversification and potentially High
returns but I also come with higher
risks and may not be suitable for all
investors it's important to know that
all Investments come with some level of
risk and it is important to carefully
consider your investment goals and risk
tolerance before making any investment
decisions
it's also a good idea to consult with a
financial advisor or investment
professional to help guide your
decisions
there you go I never thought I would
live in an age where AI tells me how to
invest money now let's move on to the
next one
number four create a monthly budget and
stick to it how do you get ahead how do
you make money
well when it comes down to it is
actually very simple your expenses
should never be more than your income
I'll say it again your expenses should
never be more than your income that's
how you get ahead and to do that you
need to plan ahead having a budget and
then you know certain things you plan
ahead knowing men next month my car
needs to go in for a service so you plan
that into your budget Jesus said in Luke
14 28
for which of you Desiring to build a
tower does not first sit down and count
the cost
whether he has enough to complete it
otherwise when he has laid a foundation
and is not able to finish all who see it
begin to mock him saying this man began
to build and was not able to finish
you know maybe you're one of those
people who come to the end of the month
or even the middle and you're like man
my bank account I mean what happened I
don't I don't understand whatever
where did everything go
that used to be me
because I didn't work with a budget and
that's probably you because you don't
work with a budget Dave Ramsey said a
budget is telling your money where to go
instead of wondering where it went
you know when I was younger
the lifestyle we had was totally
different from the lifestyle people have
today today a lot of people complain
they're in debt but
their Lifestyles it looks like someone
who's rich they eat nice food they have
nice clothing they have all the latest
gadgets that go out to the restaurants
and they spend their money on all these
things and yet they have debt and that's
because they want a luxurious lifestyle
living in Comfort even if they don't
have the money to do it so instead of
changing their lifestyle to fit in with
their budget they make loans
which then of course gets them in
financial trouble
and I carry that weight of stress with
them every day so at the end they can't
even enjoy the comfy lifestyle luxurious
lifestyle that they created for
themselves because the stress
of the Dead is suffocating them every
day that's why people across the world a
lot of them have so much stress a lot of
it has got to do with debt now we've
come to the end of part one in the next
video we're going to continue with part
two and it's going to be a few very
interesting things that I'm going to
share with you especially at the end so
I'll see you in that video and always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours just guys